[Music]
in evil stepmother news submitted by
taka that's my son's name Oh
taiga really hey Eric Griffin submitted
by weird names during the holidays a
woman was blasted online for asking a
face Kapoor to help her edit her stepson
out of a family photo if he's not in the
family anymore I get it might be ugly no
well I'm saying we don't know the whole
story
yep no we have we just drunk do we fill
in our own blanks I know but out of
cotton but I'm saying out of context we
don't know if this stepson has been a
monster
you know what if he's blinking you know
yeah indicating could have flip
could end up bug in his nose or you guys
thought that that one pattern that makes
the camera look all weird all the time
yeah it's just the truth she hates him
and wants him out of the picture but
everyone likes to jump to conclusion so
what what two-paragraph pair of caption
you're gonna read right now on reddit
and the caption says if there any way
y'all could remove the kid to the right
and these pictures he's my stepson and I
love these pictures of us together but I
also didn't get any good ones with just
two without him like with just her to
her two kids also remove him from the
full family pictures please thanks in
advance it's her husband's kid it's her
husband's child 30k dollars son I mean
her daughter's husband that's what I
thought yeah so she got these books I
don't think it was gonna be a child
here's the stepson down here in this
photo and then she ends up putting an
edit because she got she got a [ __ ] ton
of heat well yeah she got publicise she
goes edit I love my stepson but I do
want some without him in them I already
posted these ones but I just watch it's
a [ __ ] matter is the point people are
obsessed to take anything for the end
just in case they don't make it you
don't need a [ __ ]
you could just cut this [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah but here's my thing though
I have no problem with her wanting
pictures with just her kids but what she
should have done is like listen here's
what's stupid about it
hey just set up another photo shoot it's
not even a photo shoot it's just like
you just go hey can you take a picture
of me and my kids like this is not like
we're photos are like some magic thing
that you can only do once a year like
this is Jesse now that's just cruel yeah
the Eiffel Tower dude she's laid some
prairie field [ __ ] go outside with your
kids like that's this is just cruel okay
she's cruel yeah she's mean I wonder how
she really feels about the Sun even the
stuff even in the pictures little kid
what he goes all right I'm sure I'm sure
she plays favorites yeah but what I'm
saying is like let me tell you something
right now if the chick I'm with did some
[ __ ] like this yeah she's out you out
bye-bye-bye
yeah but isn't your chick pretty
attractive so it's like you can kind of
put up with it right like I don't care
how hot someone is this right here can
ruin it what is she so hot when she
bends forward you see the little
triangle like oh but she didn't tell me
that camel toe will let you let a woman
treat your kid like [ __ ] more like [ __ ]
less than that it's not in your control
I'm more likely to forgive her for it
yes in your control and I'll probably
think she's funny too
it's not me hey by the way you married
him no I just think that's like this
woman this woman's cruel and that and
wherever this dude is the husband he
don't got his house in order because you
don't you don't know that your wife
you'll hate your stepson exactly maybe
hates your kid your wife hates your kid
like no more man - why can't so he might
you know what don't be mighty he's like
[ __ ] if he's letting it happen no no no
he don't hate the kid he hates his
ex-wife yeah some parents do that they
put hate from the child this family
situation is just terrible she should
make them worry about math or something
wait what if the kid was dressed up like
Bane put a costume on real quick they
love kids love costume why is he like
that darling hey buddy orange buzz like
your car can you guys look at this again
look at the just the intimacy of the
holding the kid right there
we're in the bottom one yes the bottom
photo he's holding one like when I hurt
oh but what about the other boys they
want that to be photoshopped also
sitting on the only spot that doesn't
have grass either
there's the pollen dirt do you think
she's like hey have your dad hug you
well you know what pictures pictures
speak volumes you know oh yeah you know
that wait but which one is like he's
here where oh my god okay this one's
funny she wanted to Fant him to be cut
out of the family photo where she's just
my dad said his mom was a [ __ ] like
this his stepmom cuz his debt cuz his
mom died giving birth to him and then
his dad remarried and she came in with
their own kids and he was the youngest
right so yes like like let's say like
they bust out a cake like that and
she'll purposely cut a smaller [ __ ]
piece for him and be like that's how
much you're worth
that's why Lions got it right lions do
it right you know like kill it
yeah they just kill the kids and then
start again let's start over yeah that's
how Lions do it I think okay let's do it
that way too
[ __ ] up from human perspective but
from the animal kingdom it's just a
clean start only bar could defend that
and only I can understand yeah it comes
at me like like I'm the [ __ ] no
obviously you're doing human eyes I
agree with you I've humanized to you but
he also has analyzed lion eyes yeah yeah
there's even a song about his lion eyes
yeah guys got a little wine in them you
know you want to get whatever you know
you see with a shaker you what can I
kill this kid I'm saying I think we all
have them you thought like okay this way
I haven't dated a shake with kids before
so but my brother had an ex who and he
almost got married and I purposefully
edited her out of the family although
that I gave my mom for Christmas
I like cut her right out he's just new
usually be gone I didn't like her that's
an honest feeling that this Portland's
lead he probably had to she's like I
don't like this other kid you know so
let could be a [ __ ] dick but he's
he's like free if he was 17 and yes like
like a 25 year old woman like just like
you gotta like a little kid are you
gonna try probably whines a lot there's
nothing like someone love me dude I will
say there are some of my friends who
have a kid we're on like this [ __ ]
kid I gotta hang with this kid again
I'll edit the amount of everything cuz I
see this kid and I start going
some kids are monsters unruly monsters
well then that always but that anytime a
kid is acting like that I'm just looking
at the parents like this is you me too
this is you but what I see the kid I am
cast kid you know with my eyes can't
stand it I can't stand bad kids me too
out in public to like what do you why
just kid out here you know
scare them you don't get to do normal
[ __ ] anymore you wanted to have kids
right so you don't get to go to fancy
restaurants
you don't get to go to movies after 7:00
you shouldn't go in there I shouldn't be
on an airplane off my airplane yeah yeah
no you don't get to travel hey tell Nana
bring her ass to you okay
why can't they make a pacifier that
changes the sound of the cry into
something pleasant no like classical
music
no no just make the baby pass out no
they need to have like you know when you
go to church and they got a glassed off
area plane like a smoking section yeah
fine with tyka why are you doing it to
me we have to sometimes we try not to
why do you fly where do you go
well we have to do like a trip for our
sip team yeah where you with you with
that couple yeah we're tryna we really
try not to go we don't go to the movie
theater yeah we try really try not to
fight how do I go to the movie theater
but it's gotta be before 7:00 you got to
go to the two o'clock movie in the
afternoon where kids are running my kids
crazy side I just feel that uneven you
go at that time it's a bunch of kids
there you Skype into their [ __ ]
wedding you can't you can't Skype into a
[ __ ] sent meeting in Japan no we have
to check out a farm with a bear eyes you
don't you have a [ __ ] phone
it wanted to go to Japan come on the
phones in higher resolution than your
[ __ ] eyes let's all remember the
shitty stocking next year your ass is
booked
I will seed you we will see you need
while she try to get pregnant yeah my
wife wants to get praised by that nuts
right you want to get pregnant -
whatever well not in this video about
Christmas because she was talking about
how Christmas the Christmas season is
her favorite party because that was he
going hard no not really I actually
agree with you so some of these reddit
comments someone said this genuinely
made me sad imagine how that child felt
I bet he noticed he wasn't included like
the other two he they feel it
they're smart yeah and then the other
one said yeah Dylan said so disgusting I
hope that father reads this and divorces
her ass it's a child what has he done to
her another one said this is absolutely
deplorable but why does she have to make
it public yeah it's what does it ask
your friend like hey can I take this you
know you know I hate this kid
how can you can you help me [ __ ] on
Facebook I'm glad she did though she's
getting checks yeah so how did she call
child services if he/she didn't like the
kid like once you get with the parent
like you're also like the kid comes with
the package no no no I disagree with you
completely when you're going when you're
dating and stuff the kids not there on
the date first of all first of all you
don't even women people I know but all
this [ __ ] that happened to get into the
marriage you already fell for the person
mm-hmm you know you actually want to
make sure like you want to be like let
me see if this person is a good person
so once you find out you really like the
person then you go now I want to
introduce you to my kid that's not the
way to do it then obviously you gotta be
like well before we go further let me
bring Damian out you meet meet my little
monster because then you might be like
whoa I mean you know it's too late it's
too late because like for example for me
though like we got married
I have a son from a previous
relationship I we [ __ ] around in the
picture his own baby pictures he's like
we were together no but like so we were
dating for a little bit but we didn't
get to the point where we were like in
love and then I introduced like I kind
of felt it where I'm like well I feel
like now's a good time Chloe my point is
I don't know you already got you knew
what it all it is is kind of like I like
this guy I mean then did you in your
mind you already you were already trying
to trap him you already saw he roped
adults you rubbed a dump
admit it and you were like okay let me
get the cheetah in right away come on
here
[Laughter]
you don't want to give it to she was a
good mom she's like I don't know if this
buggers a creep I'm gonna want to [ __ ]
it no she knew what I'm saying that she
was like he's not a creep I like him I'm
attracted to him and she was like let's
accelerate this [ __ ] you don't I mean
what Renee Zellweger's do and Jerry
Maguire same as that [ __ ] she trapped me
with the kid yeah talking with a [ __ ]
kid you know what he's a great kid is in
case it's not a parent trap at the kid
treasure you know but you don't know all
that all the training she did before
that
all right this practice
[Laughter]
hey I'm saying but haven't you okay let
me ask you this before you got with him
did you date other people I did I was
trying how many I got
how many guys have met your kid just him
she doesn't date very I know but what
I'm saying is before the you know you
were luckier in looking you were like
from Isaac dad to Casey there was one
guy okay with that one guy did he meet
your kid yeah we were two guys for three
years
oh this see that's not so boring Eric
this what I deal with
[Laughter]
[Music]